number one entertainment tonight i mean
it's big wendy williams is not going
anywhere i'm gonna come in like a
hurricane so
whitney are you still using drugs he
wants to give you a talk show millions
of people turn on the radio to listen to
me you're the star
hey you held nothing back in this what
were the toughest scenes for you to
watch from the movie
well none of them were really tough
wendy i would argue with you i would say
i was shocked by the miscarriages and
knowing that
and seeing that how hard that was
because there's nothing easy about
being that pregnant and then losing a
baby and having to give birth
twice yeah yeah and then having to go
home and clean up the nursery
um days how hard were those days
those days while i was living them were
very hard especially because i knew that
kevin was cheating on me at that time
i mean kevin is kevin is a serial cheat
you know this girl who had his baby is
not the only one
and um it was shortly after we got
married that i found that out
reliving the miscarriages those seem
like such a distant memory to me because
i now have my precious son and he's 20
years old and he's
a junior in college and he's a young man
who's seen a lot
but he's going to be a better man than
me and his father could ever want from a
child and that's why you have children
uh you know he eats right he speaks
right you know the right things come out
of his mouth
um he's handled this divorce
the best he can which is pretty good i
stuck with um my ex-husband
because we had a son if we didn't have
children i would have been out
you know i would have been out but we
had a son
and we were living my career was doing
better every year my career would do
better and every year
kevin would turn into more of a jerk
because every year
my status would change higher and the
money would change higher
and the cars would get slicker and the
cars would get lower to the ground and
the cars would get flashier and all of a
sudden
going to a showroom was not good enough
he had to have the cars
made and sent over from italy or germany
or wherever
and that kind of stuff became corny to
me
for an everyday thing don't get me wrong
i do like fancy things but
i like them in doses that's where
i appreciate the way my mom and dad
raised me
i am their daughter in that you know my
son's happiness at that time was more
important than my own
how much did it anger you when people
were writing those articles like
what wendy doesn't know she should know
he's cheating and blah blah blah
it didn't bother me at all because at
that point i was in the infancy stages
of talking with lifetime about a
production deal
my deal with them is more than just this
movie i have an office over there i've
got staff i've got
i've got a full situation so i knew my
story would be told
and and yeah all you did see was what
was being talked about on et or in the
papers or on the blogs and
i didn't i i had to talk about it on hot
topics
and i knew i couldn't say anything more
than that because i didn't want to blow
my own cover
and my own cover was i had pis
on him and on her i knew
exactly where her gyn was i had my
people follow them on vacations
outside of the tri-state area okay while
i'm here
filing my nails
talking to my divorce lawyer and my team
of people and getting my ducks in a row
for me i'm just happy to make it to my
perch
yeah hey wendy hot topics which now it's
interesting to see how
in the beginning everyone was so
resistant to it and now it is something
that is the linchpin of your show
and is wildly popular what do you say to
those people who tried to stop you those
program directors are like
what are you doing what are you thinking
well i've already made up with them uh
people who fired me
um some of them have participated in my
documentary
i had one boss tell me
um watching me leave was the worst thing
that he could have had done
but his heart couldn't take me staying
around because
that was just too much you know the
bosses didn't know how to
handle you know bad boy records calling
every day and def jam records atlanta
records and wendy's talking about our
artist
now we're not going to do your big
winter concert we'll do the concert if
you fire wendy or whatever
you know all that was going on and i was
just a girl from jersey
just trying to make my way and my kevin
helped me
be that renegade he he helped me be
exactly who i was when he met me he just
joined forces
and drove he he drove the getaway car
can i just tell you something you look
really good how are you doing
health-wise how are you doing because
you look really good i feel fine i'm
doing very very well i've got
a very good team of doctors everything
from
neurologists heart doctors lung doctors
my lymphedema doctor my endocrinologist
who handles my thyroid my graves disease
and my hormones
i've got um a wonderful uh doctor who
handles
a little a little work on the cheeks and
the lips and stuff
i i mean but you know i'm doing really
well you know
my my breasts are well i don't take any
pills i don't have heart issue i don't
have high blood
pressure i take a thyroid pill and a
loon zest every day
and that's it my vitamin d levels are
back up to where they should be i stay
hydrated
i have doctor's appointments maybe every
other week
only because i have time to do stuff
like that because i don't have to be a
mother i don't have to be a full-time
mother anymore he's grown he's in miami
and i don't have to be a wife
and if you're my boyfriend then you'll
understand my doctors come before you
and my show will come before you as well
and my son will come before you
so but that's new life i expect to not
be
your first priority either you know you
got to take care of your kids and you
have to take care of your health and you
have to take care of your job
um wendy was your because we don't see a
lot of kevin was kevin all
the young kevin was he off limits and
were you kind of like i want to protect
my son
yeah i wanted to protect him emotionally
you know he's been through enough but i
mean
he only knows his mom being the show
girl on the radio with the mouth
so this is all he knows and it's only
gotten
more terrifying i guess every year of
his life because my career has gotten
bigger and bigger
i just did not want him
in present day like the documentary i
didn't want so many pictures of him
flashing in the movie and and i prefer
him not watching the movie although he
does say that he's going to watch it
he's going to watch it by himself first
then he's gonna have a watch party
um he he is um
he's off limits unless he wants to be on
limits it was his idea to post the
picture at christmas we took a picture
in my apartment at christmas
and he was the one who wanted me to put
that on instagram i said really
i said you realize that my instagram is
public and he said yeah mom you know
your mom you look great
i said well how should we dress kev and
he said well you
put on one of those stupid poofs that
you you dress how you dress mom you
dress how you dress
and i said okay and you dress how you
dress and so that's us
just chilling in the apartment merry
christmas
and it seems like you two are in such a
good place we are
the love between you two is so amazing
we are
we are and and and you know his dad
his dad i guess will always be his dad i
haven't seen
change in that way um from him but what
i do see
is my tolerance from afar to uh
understand that he will be required to
be at kevin's graduation from college
and he will be required to have better
taste than to bring
the side piece and the little girl
because i would not bring the next man
to my son's college graduation
how are you doing because it's been a
month since your your mother shirley
passed how have you yeah
are you dealing with that well
um she didn't suffer which is the good
thing and i never saw my mom in the
hospital a day in my life
in 56 years i've never seen my mother in
the hospital i've never seen my mother
down with more than anything but a cold
you know
and so the way i remember my mom
is just mom mom in a robe mom
in her party clothes mom in an evening
gown on their way
out you know mom cooking mom laughing
mom yelling at us telling me to lose
weight
i just remember mommy and she's with me
every day
and i'm coping with it the best i can
you know she passed away
a bit before i was able to share on hot
topics and
you know with you kev and and other
people i had to process it myself
because i was the one who got the call
in the morning from the doctor
my sister and her husband my sister you
know when people are in the hospital
they have two names that you can have
you know for emergency calls
and my dad is 89 years old my dad is
going to be 90 next month he doesn't
need to be getting a call
about his partner of 65 years his wife
his best friend
you know he doesn't need to be getting
any kind of calls whether it's that she
needs an
aspirin a new uh you know
nail polish or that she's passed away
so it was my sister and i who were on
the names and my sister lives in miami
so my sister was able to you know go
over to the hospital and all that other
kind of stuff
she didn't answer the phone and i was
awake it was like six o'clock in the
morning and i was awake because i was
about to come
the car was gonna be outside at seven
o'clock to bring me here to the set to
do the wendy williams show
and i was awake and i saw you know
florida i recognized the number and i
picked it up hello
um mrs hunter and so i said
um yes well yes i'm shirley's daughter
wendy my sister wanda talks to you more
yes yes yes it's miss hunter by the way
um and he said um you know we tried
we tried
we tried that's a hard call to get
it's a hard moment yeah
and i still came to work
i came to work i didn't say anything to
anyone here
i think i put that inside i think i
might have told my
manager bernie maybe even i waited to
tell him
i kept it inside for a bit of time
that's hard yeah i didn't tell anybody i
didn't i didn't tell anybody
yeah no i get i i hear that but
did you have a moment for yourself yeah
i have moments for myself all the time
how many times do i have to tell you i'm
divorced i live by myself
i've got a gorgeous apartment and two
cats who leave me alone
they they have their personalities as
well
i've got lots of time to myself and here
at the show
i have an open door policy which mr
hunter never did
you know and and kept everybody away
from me and now
that i am my own boss as opposed to
having
kevin bossing me around and telling me
what to do
and me playing the role i am in on
everything you know when the masked
singer calls
kevin thought that was corny as hell
what i when i called him up and told him
look i'm gonna be on the mask singer
my hus my ex-husband he couldn't even
find the funny in that he was like
what's that
i said it's only one of the biggest
shows on tv you don't know the master
singer stupid
and so i said watch what happens and
that was one of those moments like
dancing with the stars which by the way
he thought was corny and told me after
that
you're never doing any more of these
stupid shows all this flying back and
forth and rehearsing and
he thought that i was better than i am
in a pre-sumptuous way
can i say something watching your
journey and you look at this girl this
woman
who made this journey and you started
right at the bottom part-time jobs
everything and now you sit at the top
yeah the food chain
what when you look at this what goes
through your mind what do you say to her
who survived and fought her way to the
top
that she spilled a cup of cocoa with
marshmallows and a biscotti
right there on the floor and um i don't
want to call housekeeping to clean it up
because i want to do it myself
because that's the kind of stuff that
keeps me normal true facts
look here's the biscotti container empty
this is about 5 000 calories of biscotti
i've been eating them in between
interviews and i got some spot shot in
my bathroom
and i'm going to clean it myself and
those are the kinds of things
that keep me saying life is good
you know you got fabulous on one hand
and a mess on the other
and i'ma want entertainment tonight
it's big